I just want to thank
um all the incredible transgender
Legends before me who kicked these doors
open for me so I could be here tonight
this is a huge moment for me Sam thank
you you're a true Angel and hero in my
life Kim Petrus makes history at the
Grammys and the Grammy goes to
Unholy Sam Smith and Tim Pickers
yeah the singer took home the award for
best pop Duo group performance alongside
Sam Smith for their collab Unholy when
you need it baby
[Music]
Sam graciously wanted me to accept this
award because I'm the first uh
transgender woman to win this award
in Kim's powerful speech she thanked
those who helped her along the way all
the incredible transgender Legends
before me Sophie especially my friend
who passed away two years ago who told
me this would happen and always believed
in me Madonna for fighting for lgbtq
rights my mother I grew up next to a
highway no and nowhere Germany and my
mother believed me that I was a girl and
I wouldn't be here without her and her
support after the touching moment Kim
and Sam hit the stage once again but
this time to perform their award-winning
hit
[Music]
together
[Applause]
[Music]
it's definitely go big or go home it's
the Grammys
[Music]